so what i would like you to do is see if
you can figure out the measure of angle
d e g here so try to figure out the
measure of this angle i encourage you to
pause the video now and try it on your
own
all right now let's work through this
together and the key realization here is
to think about this angle well it is an
inscribed angle we see its vertex is
sitting on is sitting on the circle
itself and then think about the arc that
it intercepts and we see
we see that it intercepts
so let me draw
let me draw these two sides of the angle
we see that it intercepts arc cd
it intercepts arc cd
and so the measure of this angle since
it's an inscribed angle is going to be
half the measure of arc cd so if we
could figure out the measure of arc cd
then then we're going to be we're going
to be in good shape so if we figure out
the measure of arc cd then we take half
of that and we'll figure out what we
care about
well what you might notice is that there
is another inscribed angle that also
intercepts arc cd
we have this angle
right over here it also intercepts arc
cd so you could call this angle c
whoops you could call this angle
c
f d
this also intercepts the same arc
so there's two ways you could think
about it two inscribed angles that
intercept the same arc are going to have
the same angle measure so just off of
that you could say that this is going to
be that these two angles are going to
have the same measure so you could say
this is going to be 50 degrees or you
could go you could actually solve what
the measure of arc cd is it's going to
be twice the measure of the inscribed
angle that intercepts it so the measure
of arc cd is going to be 100 degrees
twice the 50 degrees and then you use
that and you say well if if the measure
of that arc is 100 degrees then an
inscribed angle that intercepts it is
going to have half its measure it's
going to be 50 degrees so either way we
get to 50 degrees